collecting analyzing and interpreting data is
a cornerstone of modern medicine it helps us
improve the lives of people around the planet by
improving how we prevent diagnose and treat human
diseases as healthcare becomes more personalized
and data-driven there's an increasing demand for
professionals who can lead the application of
data science to medicine to accommodate this
demand Sanford is now offering a graduate
certificate in epidemiology and clinical
research the certificate is a four class
program that provides students with the
knowledge and skills essential to evaluate or
run epidemiological or clinical studies the
topics we will cover our study design statistical
analysis with medical applications the basics of
probability and statistical inference beginning
and intermediate R in SAS programming critical
evaluation of the medical literature theory of
clinical research and the phases of clinical
trials leaders in the field of Epidemiology
have come together to develop this curriculum
including John Ioannidis Rita Popat and Victor
Henderson along with myself you will earn the
certificate including Stanford transcript credit
after completing four courses the program is
designed to be completed in nine months however
you may choose to extend the length to accommodate
your personal needs you can also just take one
course without needing to enroll in the entire
certificate program as part of this program
you'll have access to the same resources as
on campus Stanford students this includes a
teaching assistant and interaction with the
faculty the real power is going to come from the
marriage of the data science discipline with the
epidemiology discipline and I think that's
where the future lies and making the true
discoveries that make a real difference whether
you are a data scientist interested in working
in epidemiology an investigator overseeing
a clinical trial where someone who needs to
evaluate research and data completing this program
will set you apart as a leader in your industry